[Musique]
les élèves du collège simon lucas se
sont rendus à saint paul sur la plage en
face du cimetière marin qui est un
monument historique
il abrite la tombe du célèbre pirate la
mise ban à la partie pour un masque
bonne déchets sur la plage parce que la
plage c'était vraiment sale de moules et
marcotte de lou romain qui s'étaient
écartés du groupe
tomba sur une étrange manière
quand on est tristes patrick et où cela
on savoir si toi tu es ouais c'est parti
comme les autres
buvez du grand n'importe quoi ce romain
toujours en train de blaguer telle euros
mlapa bomboir à savoir mardi
non c'est chez moi non c'est pas des
chèques mais ça faisait des films et
c'est ce parti qui n'en font pas un
déchet vraiment moi je dis si c'est une
bouteille
elle ajouté simek via des gens ils l'ont
cherché pendant dix années et tout ce
que tu penses à faire s'est ajouté à la
poubelle bon d'accord
un merci 120
[Musique]
ah ouais
y'a quoi là
attendez blanc
c'est une carte aux trésors comme dans
les films
roma l'a découvert a fait il ressort ma
carte au trésor
l'ipo ce que c'est un a fait un
incroyable mais à quoi pouvait bien
donné cette carte
un coffre fort rempli de richesse romain
décide d'aller chercher les réponses à
ces questions dans les livres des cd
ils voulaient en savoir plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
si bon j'ai trouvé alors retrouvé
regarde hui j'ai trouvé le trésor parce
qu'on fait ça c'est bien ça louvre tous
les bus étaient bien cachés en plus on
avait raison de la remontée à quoi j'ai
déjà trouvé le trailer c'est tous à 13
en fait c'est tous les documents
et oui roma l'avez compris la cote que
l'ua trouve sur la plage semaine bien
être esor mettait pas être hors
matériels tels trésors culturels
c'était l'identité réunionnaise
[Musique]
les noeuds
là
[Musique]
non
je
[Musique]